[Music]
thank you
a very good morning it is seven o'clock
you're watching Sky News breakfast in
hospitals in classrooms and on the High
Street coronavirus continues to affect
every aspect of daily life troops are
being drafted in to support the NHS in
the capital while schools are also
feeling the strain of Staff shortages
and shops seeing a fall in customers
plenty to discuss their with the
business Minister Paul Scully coming up
for you in just a few minutes also ahead
this morning
freedom to fly we're going to be
speaking to the boss of the travel firm
jet2 as the easing of those restrictions
sees more of us setting our sights on
sunnier climbs and looking out for the
big cats we're going to be speaking to
the Bourne freestyle Virginia McKenna
about her campaign to ensure that these
incredible lions like this don't become
extinct in the wild
it is Friday the 7th of January
military might to help the Medics 200
troops are drafted in to support London
hospitals struggling to cope with a
surge in covert patients put a search of
covid-19 on top of winter pressures and
you have an extraordinary situation that
has put the NHS on
crisis in the classroom just days into
the new school term a warning of high
absences amongst both teachers and
pupils
free to leave an Australian Minister
says the world tennis number one Novak
Djokovic is no prisoner
Mr chocolate is not being killed held
captive in Australia he is free to leave
and High Street Blues new data reveals a
dramatic decline in football during what
should have been one of the busiest
shopping periods of the year
a career without the commute how more
employers are willing to embrace
flexible working and not log on in the
office
Russian troops arrive in Kazakhstan as
dozens of protesters are killed in
violent clashes
mental health warning scientists say
Global dementia cases could triple by
2050 if the main risks aren't addressed
and the weather mostly cold with a mix
of Sunny spells and wintry showers but
the weekend will be milder
[Music]
good morning 200 members of the armed
forces are being deployed to support the
NHS in London as hospitals struggle with
staff shortages due to the spread of the
Omicron variant the Royal College of
Nursing says that the move means that
the government can no longer deny that
there is a staffing crisis in the Health
Service meanwhile the headteachers union
says more than a tenths of staff and
students have been absent since the
start of the term this week warning that
schools are teetering on the edge either
Bennett reports
a new term but an old problem that's
getting much worse teacher absences are
already seeing classes combined and in
some cases emptied with the term having
barely begun
[Applause]
Elroy Cahill is a head teacher in
Hounslow West London at the moment he
only has two teachers self-isolating but
he's preparing for a lot more ultimately
you're going to have to see temporary
teachers teaching subjects which means
that students not really getting the
same experience as they would regularly
and in addition to that I think probably
there will be an impact on additional
Services provided to for example
students with special educational needs
on the first day of term alone more than
a quarter of schools in England were
missing more than 10 percent of teaching
staff due to covert related reasons
almost 1 in 10 had more than 20 percent
absent
half are already turning to supply staff
but more than a third of those say
they're unable to find cover
unions say compromises like larger class
sizes will have to be made to keep
schools open but they feel government
support is lacking
we're very very worried that school
leaders making decisions in response to
a crisis will be criticized later on for
decisions that they absolutely had to
make now so you know the government
needs to make a decision to remove those
measurements to remove those inspections
and that accountability so that school
leaders feel properly supported
in hospitals too pressures continue to
build more than 20 NHS trusts across the
country have declared critical incidents
while in London the Army is now stepping
in to help with 200 military personnel
deployed to cover staff shortages this
is a time of year that is busy even if
there weren't covid-19 and so put a
search of covid-19 on top of winter
pressures and you have an extraordinary
situation that has put the NHS on a war
footing but these vital services are now
under serious strain and the wave of
Omicron still appears unrelenting Ivor
Bennett Sky News
well let's take a look at the latest
daily covert data for the UK there were
179
756 new cases of coronavirus reported in
the past 24 hours 231 more deaths that
takes the total number of people who
have died within that 28 days of a
positive test to 149
515 well we can speak now to the
business Minister Paul Scully a very
good morning to you Mr Scully when we
have armed forces at the capitals
hospitals as being described as the NHS
on a war footing we've got a pretty
serious problem
well we know there's pressures on the
NHS and that's why we went into Plan B
Before Christmas uh and we are we
started off in a better position than we
were this time last year not just
because
um there is a bigger disconnect between
hospitalizations and case numbers but
also because we started the process the
the year with 3 000 more doctors ten
thousand more nurses than we did this
time last year but but you're absolutely
right there are pressures on staff uh
presences and people being absent and
that's why we put into place uh things
like the digital staff passport so
people can move around staff can move
around hospitals far easier the fact
that we've brought in the military as
you say to be able to support NHS staff
because we want to make sure that that
people can get through this Pro this
period in time of particular pressure on
the NHS as best but this isn't normal
though is it covered
this isn't normal though is it no
clearly
outside hospitals it is not normal and
the mod says that there's going to be
more uh more troops being deployed
expected to go to the north of England
next so there's more to come
yeah it is I mean look when you talk
about Armed Forces you know around
hospitals they're not sitting there in
combats or anything like that it's it's
more people helping out helping out the
undoubted pressures on the NHS and
that's why we want people to get out and
get vaccinated and get boosted to make
because that remains our best weapon
against the pressures on the NHS and
against covid as we learn to live with
covid
more restrictions being called for by
Medics by the NHS to avoid situations of
having armed forces in hospitals are
they still totally off the table
there's there's at the moment we're
looking at the data but we've seen
what's happening in London which was
leading the way in in the in the curve
on the case numbers and we we don't see
uh the need to do it at this moment in
time we'll clearly be reviewing our plan
B uh scenario before the 26th of January
and then we'll come to Parliament with
uh with uh the decisions that's been
taken at that time but what you find is
that any plans and any restrictions that
come in take weeks to get through the uh
the process of being infected with the
virus and then hospitalizations and
unfortunately deaths so what we're doing
now is something that will affect the
numbers in the NHS in a few weeks time
that's why we're looking at the curve
and the data on a day-to-day basis
I'm wondering how United the government
is on this particularly at senior levels
reports in the papers today that the
health secretary
um has been saying that due to the
loosening of travel restrictions which
we're seeing from today that we could
see more lockdowns what's your view
well I don't believe at this stage we we
need any more lockdowns we what we're
doing today is we're announcing the the
uh the fact that the money for
Hospitality retail and Leisure and
accommodation uh is available now for
those businesses that have been hardest
uh pressed throughout this this pandemic
and especially over that Christmas
period when Plan B came in for those
businesses to be able to approach their
local authorities to get the financial
support they need but what we've got to
do is we've got to make sure that we can
balance the needs of of everybody within
a what is an incredibly difficult
situation the pressures on the NHS but
also the pressures on the economy the
pressures on households jobs livelihoods
and indeed money that's coming in to pay
for the public services in the first
place yeah you're talking about
livelihoods there I know you are the
small business Minister here you're here
to talk to us of course about business
it's very quiet out there isn't it um
it's a very low footfall in December um
was the guidance of work from home a
mistake
and I think it's so it's the right thing
to do to make sure that people remember
that they have choices uh that they need
the flexibility to be able to not get on
the commute uh uh necessarily be
standing so close to people despite the
fact that uh you know obviously in in
London Underground and other uh and and
chains around the country and buses
people should be wearing masks uh but
nonetheless if we're just disconnecting
people in those sort of ways that helps
reduce the numbers of of cases although
as I say the case numbers are in
themselves are not the the sole measure
because there is a bigger disconnect now
between the case numbers and the
hospitalizations thanks to the
vaccination program and thanks to the
booster program
are you thinking about reversing that
guidance about work from home because
businesses are suffering
well I think what we've said is that we
we're sticking to plan B at the moment
the 26th of uh of January is the date
for the review of that so we'll look at
what what the data is saying there uh at
that um in the lead up to that to that
date but clearly we've got to get that
difficult balance right and that's
taking the views of those businesses
taking the views of the the of the
scientists and then making a judgment
call uh with Parliament fully involved
I know that you're coming on the program
because you're announcing funding today
some support for businesses some covid
support it looks very much like what you
announced on the 21st of December what
is new today
no it is exactly the it is exactly that
program what I'm saying today is that
that money is hitting the local
authorities now it's for businesses now
too that are in the hospitality uh
retail and Leisure to approach the local
authorities to make sure that they can
get that money quickly it is available
for them we want to make sure that we
can get the money to them now while it's
needed rather than letting it drag on
for for a few weeks because we know that
cash flow I used to run small businesses
for 25 years I know cash flow is
absolutely everything especially at a
pressured Point like this so any
businesses that are affected in those in
those sectors please do approach your
local Authority
you talk empathetically Mr Scully about
uh cash flow we saw some fire exchanges
in pmqs on Wednesday
um is this a government that takes the
cost of living crisis seriously because
some people would would say that perhaps
the prime minister's response on that
would suggest otherwise
we'll take it really seriously I mean we
know that the uh you know Energy prices
are are an issue that uh that the people
are worried about
um uh a cost of living in general that's
why we announced the biggest cash
increase in the National living wage
um since its Inception uh to to kick in
um in in April that's why we got rid of
the ill change the taper for Universal
personal credit which puts a thousand
pounds uh back into the pockets of the
lowest paid as well so we're trying to
make these targeted approaches whether
it's the warm homes discount the the
winter but at the same time forgive me
for interrupting forgive me for
interrupting Mr Scully we do have this
looming massive hike in energy bills
what is the government going to do about
that
well at where work we speak to uh the
energy companies themselves with off-gem
uh on on a regular basis we've been
doing that right the way through
Christmas and New Year to really see see
what we can do
um with this Global
um surgeon in Energy prices long term
clearly we need to make sure that we get
rid of the fluctuations uh and the
prices of fossil fuels by bringing in
more Renewables but there is this a
media issue that you rightly describe
about energy prices and we're working
with energy companies and off gem to see
what more we can do
well that a talk takes a while doesn't
it and implementation also takes a while
um that so it doesn't sound like you've
got any plans to immediately address
there's massive jump in bills that
people are going to be seeing very soon
well what we've got is we've got the
targeted approach uh the two to help
with fuel bills for the lowest paid in
particular so the winter fuel payments
the uh uh the the the warm homes
discount that Target millions of of the
lowest paid households across the
country to try and ease their bills but
but clearly we'll make sure that we're
working as I say with the energy
companies to see what more we can do
with those bills in the first place I
think a lot of people worried about
their energy bills aren't going to be
satisfied with that answer Mr Scully but
let's move on is it the right time to be
raising National Insurance contributions
because some people in your cabinet
would say not
well we know that uh we've talked about
the pressures on the NHS so uh that that
that
um uh Levy will initially go to uh to uh
easing the the pressures on the NHS but
clearly tackling that long-term issue of
social care which has yet been untouched
because it's been so difficult to
resolve but this is a progressive tax it
means that the
um the top 14 of earners will pay about
half of the entire Levy
um and so it is a progressive tax that
means that um if you if you earn more
you will pay more and contribute more to
that difficult intractable problem about
social care
Mr Scully some people will say that the
conservative party is way out of touch
on the cost of living just the way
people need to live their lives pay to
put food on the table I'm just wondering
um how in touch you are with all of this
um can you tell us what the national
minimum wages for example and the price
of a pint of milk
well that's the minimum wage is eight
pound 91 is going up to nine pound fifty
that's that that sits with me I mean I
don't find my on my milking points these
days I tend to buy the the four point
um larger roughly larger um uh uh cut
cartons but you know this is this isn't
about
um well how much is that when you go and
buy the large one it's not about it's
not about pop will I buy it no but it's
about it's about demonstrating to the
public that you are a government stands
the cost of living and the pressures on
people's budgets
Sam what what it's about is it it's it's
about making sure that we have a massive
pandemic as you as you unwind that
pandemic you get into the uh uh the the
global situations of Supply chains of of
energy costs affecting not just people
in Britain but people around the world
we've got to make sure that we look
after people within this country what
we're doing is we're targeting the uh in
particular the right
minimum wage
Universal Credit forgive me for
interrupting you have you have made that
point but while we are on the cost of
living and whether the conservative
party understands the pressures that
people face
um the Prime Minister recent texts
revealing uh he's asking as we know
about this already Lord Brownlow for
more than a hundred thousand pounds to
do up the tip as he as he describes it
that he is living in now that strikes me
as a party that is out of touch
now the the prime minister in terms of
the uh the issue around the flat as uh
put up an apology to Lord guy about the
the way the process uh worked in his
investigation uh we want to make sure
that actually we are tackling the
day-to-day for the especially the lowest
paid but not just the lowest paid the
people that are pressed in in um in
Middle earners as well because we're all
going through increases in energy costs
we're all um seeing the increase in
supplies whether it's building work
whether it's uh just home improvements
and uh and and all those day-to-day
things that that people having as well
and food costs
all right Paul Scully thank you very
much for your time this morning on Sky
News
thank you sir
well still to come on the show as troops
are deployed at London hospitals we'll
hear from the chair of the Council of
the British Medical Association Dr Chand
and AG fall on the pressure faced by the
NHS also ahead we're going to be
speaking to the co-author of a report
which says the UK's covert alert level
system is close to meaningless and leads
to confusion and more depths
and is the ministry of Justice guilty of
wasting hundreds of millions of pounds
that's what labor is saying this morning
we'll speak to them just after eight
o'clock and Novak Djokovic will play the
waiting game until Monday when he'll
find out if he can compete at the
Australian Open he's been denied entry
to the country due to his vaccination
status and could lose his world number
one ranking if he doesn't take part an
Australian Minister insisted this
morning that Djokovic is not being held
captive but the tennis star's mother
suggested his treatment was inhumane as
a mother what can I say if you're a
mother you can just imagine how you how
can I feel I feel terrible since
yesterday last 24 hours that they are
keeping him as a prisoner it's just not
fair it's not human
Mr jokovic is not being killed held
captive in Australia he is free to leave
at any time that he chooses to do so and
waterfalls will actually facilitate that
or the Australian tennis player Nick
curios has this morning called on his
country to do better in its treatment of
the tennis star and the world number
one's wife Elena Djokovic has also
spoken out in the last few hours she
posted this on Instagram
thank you dear people all around the
world for using your voice to send love
to my husband I am taking a deep breath
to calm down and find gratitude and
understanding in this moment for all
that is happening the only law that we
should all respect across every single
border is love
well joining me from outside djokovic's
hotel in Melbourne is Sky news's Sky
News Australia's Joel of Philip
um Joel never mind love it's all a bit
of a mess isn't it
yeah it absolutely is salmon look a
deluge of rain has just came here and
stopped the Serbian Community from
singing and dancing out the front of his
hotel showing their form of support for
him we saw a lot of protesters Gathering
here today the anti-vaccine passport
protesters and also members of the
refugee Advocate Community who say the
world's number one tennis player is
sharing this facility with refugees
who've been in the hotel waiting for
their own legal proceedings for up to
nine years Serbian authorities are
trying to get Djokovic move to a better
facility facility there was mention of a
tennis court made in court yesterday and
the Australian ambassador to belgrave
has been summoned to help in the
situation now top Melbourne lawyers are
indicating it is actually likely that
Djokovic could still take part in the
Australian Open because the legal
proceedings could be delayed until after
January 17 he next faces court on Monday
at 10 A.M he may indeed give his version
of events in there by weblink but we're
also seeing reports that number of other
Australian Open participants have
entered the country under the same terms
that medical exemption that Djokovic
attempted to enter the country under and
that more could possibly be also on the
way Sam
all right Joel thank you
well recently introduced covert
restrictions in Wales will remain in
place for at least another week the
Welsh government warned that the
country's soaring case numbers would
only continue to rise in the immediate
future the first Minister Mark Drakeford
said that keeping the alert level 2
measures which include mandatory face
masks indoors and the rule of six in
pubs and restaurants was necessary for
what he called a difficult month ahead
and from today fully vaccinated
passengers will no longer have to take a
pre-departure covert tests before
traveling to England those who are fully
jabbed will also not be required to
self-isolate while awaiting test results
after arriving in England but they will
still need to show a negative lateral
flow test within two days of arrival
and a force made up of troops from
former Soviet States and led by Russia
has arrived in Kazakhstan at the request
of the country's president
kazakhstan's interior Ministry has
confirmed 18 police and National Guard
servicemen were killed and almost 750
were wounded following large-scale
violence it also said 26 armed criminals
had been liquidated President tokev says
constitutional order had been mostly
restored
the number of people with dementia could
triple worldwide by 2050 that's
according to a new study the institute
for health metrics and evaluation
suggests it could be caused by
population growth and aging but says
that improving access to education
globally could limit the impact cases of
Dementia in the UK are project projected
to nearly double to 1.6 million in the
next 30 Years
now flexible working has become
commonplace for much of Britain's
Workforce over the course of the
pandemic hasn't it well now a leading
Insurance firm which began offering
hybrid working almost two years ago says
that it has seen a surge in demand for
those kind of jobs but there are
concerns that working from home could
lead to a widening of the gender pay Gap
as more women work away from the eye of
bosses in the office sky is Madeleine
Radcliffe has been speaking to a working
mother who has benefited from the new
arrangement
for many of us work is now more likely
to involve a cup of tea at the kitchen
table than a commute to the office
[Music]
civil working that is working from home
part-time or in job shares is becoming
more popular
it was after having my second child that
I I really knew that it was returning to
work on a full-time basis just wasn't an
option for me I just couldn't juggle
that anymore it's just an all-round much
better setup for me
according to the recruitment and
employment Confederation 25 of jobs
advertised flexible or hybrid working in
December last year up from 19 before the
pandemic
one company has been offering flexible
working since 2019 to try and attract
more women to senior roles and now
thinks the government should change the
law so all large companies do the same
we've certainly seen a very strong
demand from employees and from
candidates for them to have access to
flexibility and for it to be fairly
applied and available to all there
aren't many of us in the office at the
moment in fact the government has told
us to work from home where we can it's
one of the biggest changes of the
pandemic who knows if the world of work
will go back to the way it used to be
and with vacancies On The Rise employers
are doing all they can to attract new
staff not necessarily back to the office
hybrid and flexible working could be
here to stay
but for all the benefits of flexible
working there are risks too will people
lose out on mentorship and promotion
opportunities away from their bosses in
the office and will that end up
impacting women more
so this is a massive thing the thing
that moms want most from work is
flexibility there is a risk I suppose
that as we move to a sort of more
established patterns that the women end
up being the remote workers and the men
go back to the office and because
they're in the office they have more
influence but I strongly feel that it's
up to employers to to counter that
flexible working won't be everyone's
choice and indeed in some jobs it just
won't be possible it also has unexpected
side effects elsewhere footfall in City
centers which traditionally rely on
office workers is down and that's
impacting local businesses there are
challenges as well as opportunities in
this new world of work Madeleine
Ratcliffe Sky News
now football plummeted in December that
is compared to pre-pandemic levels High
streets saw the biggest decline with the
number of Shoppers down almost a quarter
due to the Omicron Surge and of course
those new restrictions around it let's
go live now to our correspondent Ender
Brady who is on a High Street in Reading
good morning to your Ender I guess the
High Street there behind you will be
hoping for a busy weekend
yeah to make up for all of December's
losses Samantha you know December is
traditionally the one month of the year
where big retailers try to make all of
their profits you know they rely on tens
of thousands of people coming in every
hour every day through December and
because of the Omicron variant that
simply did not happen last month also
there was the work from home advice as
well so they've taken a huge hit and we
can take a look at the numbers now that
we've got through from the British
retail Consortium so totally UK football
in December was almost 19 percent lower
than the same month in 2019 and that's
well below the three-month average
decline of 16.4 percent whereas High
Street saw an even larger decline as
football fell by almost a quarter while
shopping center visits fell by more than
two-thirds so in total the UK High
Street saw a 33.2 drop in football
compared to pre-pandemic levels for all
of 2021 all because of covert
restrictions and concerns about the
Omicron variant now looking across
Europe figures we've had today for
December Germany football down 51 France
down 30 23 percent and Italy down 37
Spain hovering around 22 so numbers down
right across the continent but they're
at scam consolation really for UK
retailers themselves indeed it is all
right Ender thank you
time to check on the weather now
[Music]
forward to brighter Skies the weather
sponsored by Qatar Airways
well today will be mostly cold with some
wintry hazards in the north but the
weekend will be much milder it's a cold
and showery start with icy stretches
most likely in the north but Southeast
England is mainly dry the Blustery
showers will be wintry for many with
snow accumulating on the Hills
especially across Ireland Northern
Ireland Western Scotland and Northwest
England some disruption is possible as
well the morning will bring Sunny spells
and further wintry showers But Central
and Eastern England look mainly fine
thunder snow is possible in the far
Northwest later more General rain and
Hill snow will move into the windy
Southwest cold for most
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
now some good news for once a dog has
been reunited with her family get this
eight years after she was stolen
oh plus you could hardly see the dog
there could you well here that is the
moment that Sussex police captured that
reunion and handed uh Cassie her name is
back to her rightful owners there was
even a surprise as the spaniel had had
three puppies two boys and a little girl
which I think we're going to show you
no that's it but that is Cassie Isn't
She Lovely and uh eight years uh without
her owners a happy story to bring you
there uh on Sky News breakfast still to
come
as troops are deployed at London
hospitals we'll be hearing from the
chair of the Council of the British
Medical Association as pressure mounts
on the NHS
[Music]
welcome back the small business Minister
Paul Scully has told us there is no need
for another lockdown or new restrictions
at the moment that is despite numbers of
members I should say of the armed forces
being deployed to support the NHS in
London as hospitals there struggle with
staff shortages due to the spread of the
Omicron variant and schools also warning
of high absences amongst both teachers
and pupils we've seen what's happening
in London which was leading the way in
in the in the curve on the case numbers
and we we don't see uh the need to do it
at this moment in time we'll clearly be
reviewing our plan B uh scenario before
the 26th of January and then we'll come
to Parliament with uh with uh the
decisions that's been taken at that time
I don't believe at this stage we we need
any more lockdowns we what we're doing
today is we're announcing the sort of
the uh the fact that the money for
Hospitality retail and Leisure and
accommodation uh is available now
uh Rob I know you were listening to that
today we are at the 7th of January the
26th of January is when we might get
some revision of uh restrictions it
didn't sound like there's anything on
the cards there but it feels like quite
a long time with the situation the way
it is yeah I think Paul Scully was at
Payne's to point out there that the
situation in the NHS is not normal I
think there's been maybe a feeling
within the NHS that that hasn't been
acknowledged enough
um from the political side but also I
think reinforcing the sense that you've
got in government that actually the view
um in the cabinet amongst ministers and
amongst conservative MPS is hardening
against more restrictions coming in Paul
Scully pointing to London saying we're
watching the data there that suggests to
me that because there's some evidence
that London may be through its peak in
terms of some age groups um anyway the
thinking in government May well be well
if we can make it through the London
Peak without more restrictions the rest
of the country hopefully should be able
to follow as well of course that doesn't
necessarily add up because different
hospitals and different areas have their
own pressures I think as well even if
the prime minister is winning some
brownie points with his MPS for not
bringing in more restrictions that there
is a looming battle over the cost of
living we know prices are going up very
fast we know energy bills will be going
up in April when the price cap is lifted
on that maybe a hint that there's
something more to come Paul Scully
saying they were talking to energy
companies about what more can be done
but really no nothing firm no
commitments there he said they were
taking targeted measures we know what
labor and some conservative back
benchers want to see is something more
broad perhaps that on energy bills being
cut perhaps some environmental tax is
being cut as well I don't think there's
any indication that that will happen in
fact Paul Scully in there telling you
that the way to get rid of these sorts
of fluctuations is to move away from
fossil fuels towards more Greener energy
yeah indeed well we'll see what labor
has to say about it when we interview
Steve Reed shortly uh past eight o'clock
this morning thank you Rob
uh more now on the NHS backlog and the
severe pressure that Healthcare
professionals are currently facing with
me this morning is the council chair of
the British Medical Association Dr Chand
nagpul Dr nagpur good morning to you
um when we have a situation with armed
Personnel at London hospitals it's
really an image of an NHS under severe
stress
yes I mean we are seeing uh
unprecedented levels of Staff absence
within the NHS and although you know the
government has resorted to the Army
helping out in London uh let's not
forget that we actually have a national
problem at the moment uh in fact 24
Hospital trusts have declared critical
incidents
um you'll know that in Greater
Manchester 15 of Staff have been
reported off sick or or isolating in the
northeast of England and ambulance trust
has even been advising some patients
with suspected Strokes or heart attacks
to actually make their own way to
hospital because of one-hour delays so
you know this is a national problem and
and we've never known this level of
Staff absence before
we spoke to Grant chaps on the program
earlier yesterday in fact and he was at
Payne's to point out that actually the
winter time is when we often see various
trusts declare critical incidents just
because of the number of people who are
ill but from what you're saying that
this isn't normal at all is is it
frustrating do you feel that the
government isn't taking this seriously
enough
yes because I I mean the thing is that
every winter of course the NHS has
additional pressures but I don't think
anyone who's worked in the NHS has
experienced this level of absence of
their colleagues and we're feeling it
very in very real time because we're you
know doctors and nurses and healthcare
workers are having to cover for their
absent colleagues that's adding
additional exceptional strain the other
difference this winter is that not only
are we trying to uh cope with the
pressures of covid and please can I add
that although um Omicron is is said to
be a mild illness it is actually
affecting many people uh who are
becoming uh seriously ill and
hospitalization rates have doubled since
the middle of December and we're seeing
now more than 2 000 patients being
admitted every single day to hospital
which which again is as high as it was
in in the in the last uh wave a year ago
so um there are pressures and and then
we've got about six million patients on
waiting lists uh 312 000 of them have
been waiting more than 12 months for
treatment so when you add that to the
mix you can see the pressure we're under
and and I you know I can't emphasize
enough that it is having a very real
um uh uh an impact and this impact on on
real people who may have been waiting
months for an operation to see them
canceled because we just don't have the
staff or the beds to treat them and Dr
nagpur the whole rationale for the
restrictions that the government has
brought in starting back at the
beginning uh in March 2020 was all about
protecting the NHS and preventing it
from being overwhelmed uh how close are
we to that point would you say now today
you know I I think that um uh you know
the words like overwhelmed I mean I
think we should just look at the reality
the reality of the army having been
drafted into London the reality of 24
hospitals having declared critical
incidents the reality of having some
hospitals having to cancel all their uh
routine surgery
um the reality of of General practices
having to cancel uh clinics on the day
uh I'm a GP I've never known it uh this
bad where we are having to literally uh
contact patients without notice saying
that that the staff member adopter nurse
just isn't in today because they're
self-isolating this is not normal and
therefore if the government does need to
recognize this is clearly an NHS under
extreme pressure and the living reality
sadly for thousands of patients is
they're experiencing that that they're
suffering the the the consequences of
such pressures or and also staff absence
uh and what do you think about the
current strategy of sort of riding
Omicron out would you have reevaluated
that at the beginning would you would
you reevaluate it now
now obviously I'm a doctor representing
doctors and I work in the NHS and so my
perspective is from the NHS and it's
really important I believe that the
government doesn't uh just wait to ride
this out because every day people are
suffering every day we're not able to
provide the care that our patients need
and that there are really you know two
or three things that must be done one is
we do need to bring down uh levels of
Omicron uh infections in the community
because Healthcare staff and as are all
Frontline key staff
um just members of the general
population if you have such high levels
of underground over 200 000 on many days
last week on a daily basis you will have
NHS staff and other staff uh isolating
and I feel it's as simple as that so the
infection rates do need to be brought
down the second thing is we need to
ensure that those of us who are working
on the front line who are mixing with
patients who are infectious that's our
jobs need to be properly protected and
one of the things we've been calling for
is as higher grade masks that can
filtrate the Airborne spread of um
covid-19 and Omicron as opposed to the
normal paper surgical masks that don't
so we need to protect ourselves uh at
work and the third thing is to make sure
we actually do have ready access to
lateral flow tests
because of course uh it's having that
negative test on day six and seven that
has allowed Healthcare staff to return
to work after seven days isolation
rather than 10 days but in some
instances we're still hearing of uh
Healthcare staff unable to access the
test because their local pharmacy you
know has run out of stocks and so forth
all right stressful times for all of
those working in the NHS Dr nagball
thank you very much for your time this
morning
thank you
well also making news this morning
police in New Mexico say that they are
working with police in New York City to
recover Alec Baldwin's phone that's
following the fatal shooting of a
cinematographer on the set of the film
rust it comes almost three weeks after
an official warrant was issued to seize
the actor's iPhone to examine text
messages and emails related to that
incident
and the deadly wildfire that swept
through parts of Colorado last week
caused at least half a billion dollars
in damage that is according to official
estimates two people are still missing
and over a thousand homes were destroyed
near Denver in the most destructive fire
in the state's history President Joe
Biden is expected to visit Colorado
today to see the damage
and one of Scotland's two nuclear power
plants is being permanently shut down
almost 46 years after it started
generating electricity bosses at
hunterston B in North Ayrshire said that
it had produced enough energy to power
every home in Scotland for nearly 31
years since it began operating
now let's have a quick look at
everything that's happening in the World
of Sport with Jackie morning Jackie
whoa calm down Johnny it's only a game
brought to you by Vitality sharing the
benefits of healthy living
good morning Sam we start in Sydney
where Johnny Bear stays unbeaten Century
helped England's cricketers fight back
on day three of the fourth ashes test
with Australia after England lost four
wickets for just 14 runs in the morning
session bear Stone Ben Stokes put on 128
runs to help dig England out of trouble
however Stokes and Josh Butler then fell
in quick succession to put England back
in trouble at 173 for six
but Mark Wood then provided excellent
support to bear so hitting some big
shots to help England avoid the
follow-on
wood fell late on but there was still
time for bairstow to reach his hundred
he'll be at the crease tomorrow morning
when England resumed 158 runs behind
Australia with three first Innings
wickets left
Manchester City will be without Pep
Guardiola for tonight's FA Cup tie
against Swindon after he tested positive
for covid the Football Association have
said all of this weekend's ties will go
ahead despite numerous coveted outbreaks
City now have 21 first-team staff
isolating including seven players
a week into the transfer window one of
the first major deals could be very
close now two premier league clubs are
looking to sign former liftball forward
Felipe coutinho on loan from Barcelona a
reunion with former anfield teammate
Stephen Gerrard at Aston Villa is one
possibility Gerard wouldn't speculate on
that yesterday though coutinho will
reveal his destination later on today
in basketball there were wild scenes in
the NBA as the New York Knicks earned a
win in the final seconds of their game
with the Boston Celtics last night with
a Game ending buzzer just about to sound
New York's RJ Barrett produced this
three-point shot to give the Knicks the
Victory and just look what it meant to
their players and their fans
the England cricket team just dreaming
of having scenes like that at some point
we will have reaction from The Crickets
later on and don't forget all the key
transfer news on Sky Sports News
throughout the day we're back in our
time
handball handball handball ref handball
riff
stay with us still to come on Sky News
breakfast we'll be speaking to the
co-author of a report which says that
the UK's covered alert level system
remember that is close to meaningless
and a danger to the public
foreign
[Music]
suggests that the UK covered alert level
system is close to meaningless that's as
the five levels are not linked to a
specific action and the reports
co-author Dr Karina Fernley joins me now
a very good morning to you Dr Fernley I
think the public could be forgiven for
not remembering what this covert alert
system is perhaps you could remind us
a couple of months into our pandemic and
the government established an alert
level system much like many other
countries in the world some already had
some in place but the UK set our
national alert level system in place but
of course since then
um we have seen um a number of different
changes so beginning uh we had the issue
of the fact that this was supposed to be
a nationwide system and actually this
then went into different nations and so
Scotland Northern Ireland and and Wales
develop their own um versions to
accommodate their own requirements
um and then so it became just an English
system and then we had um later on in
October we had the tier system put into
place with levels uh two one two and
three
um and then we've had all sorts of
different systems since then including
etow rule for six we've had um lockdowns
we've had step one two and three earlier
last year
um and then we've had normal and so yes
indeed I think the public are very
confused because not only do we have an
alert level system but we are using lots
of different systems the alert level
system is changing levels but actually
that level doesn't have any impact on
the public and so in this report that
was commissioned by the national um
preparedness commission and we have been
looking at how can we enhance warnings
and do them better and so we've really
focused um on the covert alert level
system in terms of the immediate impact
that we could potentially have for the
public and going forward as this
pandemic continues when you describe
there Dr Fernley all the different
scenarios that we've had it's a reminder
isn't it painful reminder of how long we
have all been living with covid you
describe the system as meaningless what
are the consequences of it being
meaningless
yes I think the the meaningless aspect
comes into play Because the actual alert
level doesn't relate to action so if we
look at different alert level systems
that are very effective around the world
and we can look at those for natural
hazards or human main hazards but if we
just stick to covert we've got systems
such as that used in New Zealand for
example
um and the Philippines
um and Thailand and Singapore and North
Korea South Korea sorry
um and we have examples of alert level
systems where there are specific actions
tied to each level so it's very clear
for example in the New Zealand system
that has been very well promoted on the
media across the world as well as New
Zealand
um to highlight what needs to be done at
each level and this means having
specific guidance for different sectors
so it will be you know alert level three
this is what it means for Hospitality
education for the public for tourism for
travel and so on and it just makes it
really clear because it provides a
really great framework work in which
people can see where they're at and so
you move up and down in that framework
and you know what your requirements are
what the rules are and of course you
know this is an emerging situation it's
complex and the problem is Dr Fernley is
if if you don't believe in the signal
value or whatever the system is then you
stop trusting it and once the public
stops trusting then they don't comply
absolutely and so if you don't have that
um trust and this and the real trust is
issues coming here is because the system
keeps changing so so to begin with when
the alert level system was set up
um the the public were in a way mocking
what was going on quite quickly because
it became very clear that these systems
were redundant and they weren't being
used they didn't have any consequences
on what the public were doing like we're
seeing in other systems and so
essentially we were seeing things like
you know Nando's versions more recently
we've had Ryanair mock the alert level
system the covered alert level system
and this really comes down to this sort
of changing systems a lack of deep trust
people don't know where they're standing
the systems are changing and this is
causing a huge amount of confusion okay
Dr Karina Fernley thank you very much
for your time this morning thank you